I signed an NDA but I we do have I have
two pilots at Bravo right now so god
damn it one way or another I'm gonna get
on that Network um two very exciting
pilots and we will know by January or
February because that's when the options
up so but it's an interesting you know
reality shows and television still have
an incredible reach but it's going to be
very interesting to see what happens as
that reach is diminished by this
fractionalization of eyeballs I say that
what's happening is scrap entertainment
in other words tiny little things that
you that don't have a large cost to
produce can become entertainment now
like an actor holding up a canon camera
and saying blah blah this is what I'm
wearing right now all of a sudden that's
entertainment
you